a lot of you guys have been asking us to
take the new 2020 $1,800 MacBook Pro and
combine it with an eg pu and then
compare that to the base 16 inch MacBook
Pro by itself to see which setup is more
powerful for things like video editing
and other performance tasks so we did
just that and we found some results that
you probably aren't expecting but before
we get into those performance results I
want to first show you guys the
enclosure in the graphics card that we
chose for this build and why we
recommend those parts the razor core X
for $300 has been the most reliable in
our experience so it's a great choice
and you also have the option of
upgrading to the chroma model which
features RGB lighting and extra ports
for connecting things like a mouse and
keyboard as for the graphics card We
strongly recommend buying the 5700 XT
for 380 dollars it is by far the best
choice and we've proven that when we
compared it to other popular cards and
not only that but Apple has added a new
W 5700 X graphics option for their 2019
Mac Pro workstation which will be
shipping very soon the reason this
matters is because it's essentially
identical to the 5700 XT graphics card
that we recommend except for the vram
difference so this means the Apple is
going to be releasing new drivers for
both of these cards so the 5700 XT is
going to be getting faster over time so
with this a GPU the total price of the
13-inch MacBook Pro EGP you setup
becomes two thousand four hundred and
eighty dollars which is actually more
expensive than the base 16 ish MacBook
Pro but the benefit is that you get
great portability for when you're on the
go and then a big boost and graphics
power while plugged into the each of you
at home now before we get into video
gaming 3d rendering and video editing
performance you need to know the most
important thing about using the e GPU
setup you absolutely must use it within
external display if you want to get the
most power out of it and on top of that
we add
she noticed that plugging the display
into certain outputs on the graphics
card gave us better performance so
you'll have to experiment with this and
test out the different outputs to see
which one gives you the best performance
so just to give you guys an idea of the
performance difference the 13-inch
MacBook Pro by itself scored ten
thousand a hundred and sixty six points
in Geekbench 5s metal graphics test
which is decent for a 13-inch laptop but
with the EGP you set up plugged into an
external monitor that score went up to
thirty one thousand a hundred and
twenty-two tripling the graphics
performance however this is actually a
lower score than what this card is
supposed to get and we think it's
because of a driver issue that should
hopefully get fixed when Apple updates
the drivers for the Mac Pro's w50 700 X
graphics card but luckily we discovered
a method to work around this driver
issue by connecting two displays at once
to the e GPU and with that we got a
better score of over 53,000 and there's
a chance that it could get even better
with three displays now you're probably
thinking there's no way I'm gonna use
two displays with my MacBook Pro and the
good news is that you don't have to you
can actually buy a couple of these cheap
HDMI dummy adapters which trick your a
GPU into thinking that their actual
displays and then you get those extra
performance gains without having to buy
expensive monitors well leave some links
down to those dummy adapters in the
description so without further ado let's
first get into video gaming performance
starting with the classic Unigine Heaven
gaming benchmark on the extreme preset
the MacBook Pro alone only got 13 and a
half FPS in this test but with the e GPU
that score shot up to 70 FPS completely
blowing away the 16 inch MacBook Pro in
terms of gaming performance so then we
played some fortnight to see which
option worked better using the
recommended settings that you see right
here and we saw that the e GPU set up
completely blew the 16 inch MacBook Pro
away
so we then adjusted the settings to
1440p resolution but turned off a lot of
the extra graphics settings and the 16
inch MacBook Pro barely improved so you
can see that the e GPU is by far
the best choice for gaming next up we
tested blenders quick graphics benchmark
in the e GPU setup
wiped the floor with a 16 inch MacBook
Pro mostly because the 5700 XD graphics
card has 8 gigabytes of video memory so
for graphics rendering the e GPU is
definitely the better choice and now
let's get into video editing starting
with the graphics heavy Bruce X
benchmark in Final Cut Pro 10 here we
can see that the e GPU setup is actually
almost twice as fast as the base 16 inch
Pro and it made a huge difference
compared to the 13-inch Pro by itself
and for our 22nd 4k stabilization test
the EGP you helped the 13-inch match up
to the 16 so we can see that it's really
helping for these graphics heavy tests
however when we start to move over to
our exporting tests like this
five-minute 4k h.264 clip which is the
codec that most youtubers use the 16
inch MacBook Pro finished quite a lot
faster even though the e GPU did help
the 13 inch MacBook Pro finish almost
twice as fast now the reason the 16 inch
is faster is that when you're exporting
videos the data has to go from the CPU
to the each of you for graphics
processing and then back to the CPU and
all of that has to happen within a
single cable which has limited bandwidth
but with the 16 inch MacBook Pro the
dedicated graphics chip is connected to
the CPU by incredibly fast PCI Express
Lanes with less latency and much more
bandwidth so what finishes the export
faster even though the graphics
performance is lower and because of that
we see very similar results in the Canon
C 200 raw
60fps export test with the 16 inch
MacBook Pro winning once again now in
terms of timeline smoothness the 16 inch
wins again with close to the full 60fps
of the clip but for the 13-inch MacBook
Pro you don't get a very smooth
experience even with the each of you
helping it out a bit so as we can see
for video editing within Final Cut Pro
10 the e GPU definitely helps out but
the 16 inch MacBook Pro is still the
best choice especially for exporting
videos
now we also tested black magic resolve
studio and we actually got some very
different results we ran the same
20-second 4k stabilization test and we
can see that our times got a bit slower
all around and that's because Final Cut
Pro is the king of stabilization but one
interesting difference is that the e GPU
was the winner by far and that's because
resolve studio is actually more
optimized for each GPUs than Final Cut
Pro currently is and now running that
same 5-minute 4k export test we can see
that the speeds got a bit quicker but
the sixteen inch MacBook Pro is still
the clear winner because of those
bandwidth limitations with the HBU now
by far the biggest difference we saw
with the e GPU was in the Blackmagic Raw
test exporting this clip took over an
hour on the 13-inch MacBook Pro by
itself but with the help of the e GPU it
took only four minutes in 25 seconds
but surprisingly the 16 inch MacBook Pro
still finished quicker but the more
important difference is the timeline
smoothness the 13-inch Pro can only play
this back at three frames per second
which is unbearable if you're trying to
edit video but with the e GPU it plays
back at perfectly smooth 24 fps just
like the 16 inch MacBook Pro now before
I get into my conclusion for this video
I do want to mention that in a GPU is
gonna do absolutely nothing for things
like programming photo editing and using
Logic Pro 10 so don't even think about
wasting your money if you do those
things on your macbook but from all of
the tests that we just ran we can
conclude that if you play games that
each APU is a must and honestly for
gaming you don't actually need the
$1,800 13-inch model the base $1300
model will perform close to the same and
we'll show you guys that when we test it
sometime next week so if you're not
already subscribed go ahead and do that
right now so you don't miss out we also
notice that for 3d rendering the e GPU
was once again the better choice since
it's so graphics heavy but for video
editing we can conclude that the 16 inch
MacBook Pro is by far the better choice
since it's not only faster in most of
the tests but it's cheaper
and you don't have to deal with
everything that comes with the ETP you
however if here's somebody who
absolutely must have the portability of
the 13-inch MacBook Pro or if you
already have a 13-inch then investing
about six hundred and eighty dollars
into the e GPU setup is in excellent
choice and it'll make a big difference
for video editing as well so if this
video helps you make a decision
we'll have links to each of the Mac
books and the easy bu parts down in the
description below so go ahead and tap
the like button and click the circle
above to see our 13-inch MacBook Pro
each of you video coming soon thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]